I guess though for you  there's been dozens there's been dozens  of people reportedly murdered there's  been hundreds of arrests  so every single one of those to you in  your mind think what could be happening  to that person that's quite that must be  quite a burden actually to carry because  it must bring a lot back it does but  also  my story was a Happy Ending Story I came  out of it alive and what really makes me  upset is in some of the cases that we  see on a daily basis we have got nikash  Army who was 16 and she was a resident  she was killed and her family found her  body  I mean they they brought their body back  to the family about 10 days after she  was disappeared so in many of the cases  they do not actually come back alive  and I think the world cannot turn a  blind eye this is just not acceptable